sex a simple word for a simple act and
so of course men complicated a child
born to a wife is a gift from the gods a
child born to a mistress or an obedient
serving girl is a bastard unworthy of
its father's name so instead we call the
children after the land where they were
born flowers in the rich and hail in the
westerland's stone in the veil and storm
in the Stormlands rivers in the river
lands and waters in the Crown lands Pike
in the Iron Islands snow in the north
and in Dorne sand by these names
everyone can recognize a bastard
even if his own father won't though
sometimes a father with too much gold
and daughters will ask the King to
legitimize a bastard son and give him
his family name if his wife objects the
next one does not
but sometimes the gods play their jokes
and later his wife will give him a
trueborn son of their own when this
happens well children die all the time
so the father's even the beautiful
Targaryen said bastards when brothers
tired of their sisters many took the
name black fire after the conquerors own
sword when Aegon the unworthy
legitimized all his bastards on his
deathbed they rose up against his true
born heir Westeros bled Dorne yond
for most of Westeros the Blackfyre
rebellion only proved what they already
knew
bastards are treacherous born of lust
and shame but here in Dorne lust is not
shameful we know that bastard he does
not make a man more treacherous than
another man does not need the help